I am so sick of hearing the universal post election take. Um,
that the left just needs a new Joe Rogan,
when in fact the left needs an entire new media ecosystem.
Trump didn't win the election because of one bald,
you know, transphobic podcaster.
He won the election because there's a very organized,
very well funded group of donors
who fund propaganda machines cosplaying as media companies.
I wrote about it on my sub stack.
Just take the Daily Wire.
It got 4.77 million in seed funding from the Will Brothers,
if you don't know who that is.
They got rich from fracking.
They also donated to Bragger AU
which is like a content farm factory, um,
that cosplays as a um, university.
And then there's Project Veritas,
which is known for uh,
literally fraud. Um,
and they got a point.
One point seven million dollars from Daughter's Trust,
which is the Cook Brothers.
And then there's Russia. Who can forget about Russia?
They gave uh, right wing influencers up to $100,000 for one video.
Who could forget Elon Musk?
I don't even wanna get into it.
I mean literally. But the right isn't just well funded,
it is also willing to lie.
It is not just well funded,
it is also willing to cheat.
Left doesn't have a regard or dog
because we would never lie on national television
and create a national conspiracy
that our candidate lost the election because it was stolen.
The left, um,
isn't winning because We're too progressive.
Or um, you know,
we don't have enough male podcasters.
There's a. There's a lot already.
The left is losing
because we are trying to copy the other teams playbook
when they are cheaters. So
instead of self modulating
and trying to copy what the fascists are doing,
we should also play dirty.
That means that the left needs to enter its insufferable. Tara. Um,
you know, yes,
Joe Biden parting his son is a good start.
But why stop at your family um.
When you could pardon all abortion related crimes? Um.
And activists and doctors.
Instead of wagging our finger at Donald Trump's immigration policy, um,
Joe Biden could spend the next few weeks that he has an office
closing down the very detention centers
that Donald Trump needs to deport millions of people.
We have to stop uh,
imitating the rights playbook and we need to actually start uh,
outsmarting them and being not very demeanor and not very mindful.
That's how we win.